[Musique]
bonjour monsieur
l'angleterre est désormais un pays tiers
des pays bas depuis le site vous n'êtes
plus autorisé à entrer en europe avec de
la nourriture comme de la viande des
fruits des légumes ou du poisson
toutes ces choses là stop et de la
discorde
le sandwich de ces anglais quelques
fruits et légumes une conserve des
tranches de fromage et du pain de mie
voilà le type de panier repas que
reçoivent les familles britanniques
défavorisés pour nourrir leurs enfants
pendant cinq jours alors que les écoles
sont fermées
le tout pour une valeur annoncée de 30
livres sur les réseaux sociaux les
photos de parents indignés se
multiplient cet internaute par exemple
montre tout ce que l'on peut acheter
avec un peu plus de 33 euros il ya de la
viande dans tous les sens de reach ouais
ok donc on va tous les prendre je suis
désolé vraiment est-ce qu'on peut
enlever la viande et je récupère le pain
nantes on va être confisquée dominant
dixit monsieur désole jean jacques c'est
pas possible
jean-jacques qu'est ce qui s'est passé
aa priori pas grand chose la dernière
fois que jean-jacques à nettoyer on
devait être encore en francs
l'engin sera possible allez entrer ils
n'osent même pas entrer dans ce qui
s'apparente à une reconstitution d'une
cuisine de pompéi juste après l'éruption
du vésuve c'était donc et on bat l'air
vraiment partout sur les affiches et on
dit c'est là c'est le petit bizutage
aulas
je cuisine la wii arrête tes conneries
pas vraie révélation
la machine à laver je lui ai offert il
ya cinq ans l'été neuf ans
punaise nom de scène on a refermé il ya
des grenouilles les meilleurs jeux pour
poussines rien de gains vanessa epita
c'est ça que j'ai un an
pour peu que vous êtes là à ses bases et
moi c'est moi le temps là bas j'étais là
bas
la porte était ouverte je sais pas
comment on peut appeler ça qu'est ce
capharnaüm william aaron ou des charges
la salle de bains voilà tu vois c'est
l'endroit où c'est un peu près de trois
points à peu près propre et trash eh oui
la propreté est une notion relative à
chacun
[Musique]
basket
je voudrais vous dire un jeu avec sommes
une société d'accord voulait en pâture
notre nom le nom de notre société
mon nom mon prénom en faisant optique
musique derrière du pipeau et qualité
rare qu'on ait des arnaqueurs et tout à
ça c'est vous qui l'avez dit mieux
n'attendez pas de monsieur c'est vous
qui connaît de dieu et étienne
arnaqueurs je n'ai jamais dit non parce
que moi j'ai pas des renseignements
qu'elle prouver ou sans citer de marque
quel est le truc le plus inutile que
vous ayez acheté il y en a beaucoup à
voir le couteau qui coupe les chaussures
bon ben je le dis à mes petits-enfants
bondir mamier folle mais le savent déjà
un peu c'est un rouleau ou là ou pas là
ouais au fait il est encore dans la
boîte mais pourquoi l'avoir acheté mais
parce que ils le vendent bien géré c'est
que monsieur parler comme ça ça ne sert
à rien envoyez-moi les mails qui prouve
que vous avez raison et on réglera le
problème si c'est pour dire ceci et cela
vos clients or là monsieur donc votre
avocat dit que vous ne vouliez pas
parler en plus il appelait hier blanche
grands médias ce jeu l'on peut parler
tous les que le concours de celui qui
sera le premier
croyez moi j'ai un peu d'habitude vous
ne gagnerez pas c'est quoi ça y est
sarah cgil s'est ainsi regarder ailleurs
mais si on fait des découvertes de
taille
je vais y passer la parole à madame la
présidente de la commission européenne
va d'amour sous la fin d'un règne pour
cela merci beaucoup d'être avec nous cet
après midi
hop soul en ne tentant pas tu dois être
un minutes on ne t'entend micro coupé on
n'entend pas l'intervention de madame la
présidente
on ne tentant pas et si disney faisait
un long métrage sur la politique
française
voilà à quoi cela pourrait ressembler le
policiers repèrent un petit groupe de
jeunes qui dérange les touristes avec
ses collègues il décide de les rappeler
à l'ordre avant que les choses ne
dérapent toi puisque dans deux minutes
ça va être mon temps à me défaire plus
quoi c'est bon les années
baladez-vous aller draguer les gonzesses
pour mener vous la dépêchez vous allez
allez allez
j'ai parlé promenez-vous j'ai pas envie
de parler les gars promenez vous
dépêchez vous elle a essayé de
s'introduire entre nous mais ça n'a pas
marché parce que ben voila j'ai un gros
cul comment tu veux qu'elle vienne tu
veux qu'elle vienne ou en fait elle peut
pas en fait
omar sy c'est la question que vous pose
est est-ce qu'il peut coller des
affiches dans le métro sans être reconnu
et bien la réponse est oui vous allez
voir il a posté si bien tu le reconnais
il a haussé cette vidéo hier sur les
réseaux avec ce poste vous avez vu la
fiche mais avez-vous vraiment regardé
qu'il a posé à l'eni vu ni connu
il est à l'air celine affiche de la
série sur un quai du métro parisien à la
station au palais royal musée du loup le
jour oui mais
chez toi ça va coller merci beaucoup
c'est très gentil
on est dans un moment on a l'impression
qu'on est sur un on nous a jetés d'un
bateau vous savez on est sur un radeau
parce que regardé dans le bateau les
commerces essentiel et puis nous on
n'était pas alors on a l'impression
d'être traité un peu comme des jets pas
des périodes des gens qui sont
finalement pas important alors je parle
moi au nom de tous les artistes parents
mon nom tout ce sont michel souffrance
mais oui c est vous le dis presque avec
le regard qu'il faut c'est une année qui
commence fort pour elie semoun alors que
l'humoriste avait l'intention de
souhaiter une bonne année à ses abonnés
de façon humoristique instagram n'a
visiblement pas saisi l'humour de
l'artiste qui a été censuré à deux
reprises un message dans lequel il
commencé par faire des excuses à
plusieurs communautés
je vais m'excuser aussi auprès de la
communauté noire musulmane et juive
j'ai dérapé avant de conclure par aller
saluer au pardon je m'excuse auprès de
la communauté homosexuelle
parce qu'on parle du culte mais le
théâtre c'est une communion les gens
besoin d'aller dans des endroits où ils
sentent quelle chaleur humaine
aujourd'hui quand on se promène dans les
villes il ya ya plus à enfin donc qu'on
nous le qu'on nous laisse la voie dans
des endroits où on peut se réunir avec
une grande organisation à grand respect
merde il faut être conscient de son
bonheur quand on la pensait que non mais
non donc tu te sens tu t'assois tu
fermes ta gueule tu m'énerves sexy tu la
boucles quoi c'est ça